Speaker 1: we're continuing to track
what's happening with this Omicron
variant and booster mandates are starting.
The United Kingdom is setting new records.
Speaker 2: It is an
Speaker 1: explosion of information and of panic.
Speaker 2: And I
Speaker 1: understand the
Speaker 2: worry, and I
Speaker 1: also still don't know that
it is warranted on the basis of what we
Speaker 2: know about Omicron.
Speaker 1: So let's go
Speaker 2: through
a few different
Speaker 1: aspects here.
Speaker 2: Businesses, many
Speaker 1: employers and universities
are now saying fully vaccinated
Speaker 2: means three shots,
Speaker 1: not two.
Speaker 2: Now, however
Speaker 1: serious Omicron is the early
Speaker 2: data. The early data
Speaker 1: is that if you have three shots, you
are significantly less likely to get a symptomatic
infection of Omicron than if you have two shots
now on asymptomatic. We don't yet really know
on effectiveness on against
Speaker 2: serious illness
Speaker 1: or death. We're still getting
information. It seems three shots are
somewhat better, but three shots
seem significantly better than two
against Omicron, against symptomatic illness. So
that's really important. So the Metropolitan Opera
yesterday said if you want to be an
Speaker 2: eligible audience member
Speaker 1: or an employee,
Speaker 2: you need that third shot
Speaker 1: a Georgetown NYU. Some private
colleges have said you're going to need your
third shot. Number of universities
where I know people working say that
when you come back for the spring semester,
Speaker 2: you've got to have that third
Speaker 1: shot. The NFL is requiring
coaches and staff to get booster shots
by December 27th, and the
Speaker 2: real question here is what
Speaker 1: is actually going on with the
Omicron variant. And I know we continue to say
it's early. We still need more data. We still
need to wait. It continues to be that on average,
Speaker 2: if you get
Speaker 1: the Omicron variant,
you are less likely to get really, really sick
Speaker 2: by virtue of being more contagious,
Speaker 1: which it appears to
be. The burden on society can
Speaker 2: still be large,
Speaker 1: and we are seeing even
advance of Omicron being the reason. Even still
with Delta, we're starting to see hospitals in
different states increasingly
Speaker 2: fill up,
Speaker 1: so that's one aspect of
what's going on. The CDC has issued a
Speaker 2: forecast that cases
Speaker 1: weekly are going to be up to
Speaker 2: 1.3
Speaker 1: million
by Christmas Day and that deaths are going to
surge 73 percent to over 15000 a week when and
as Omicron becomes the dominant strain. And
again, some people hear that and they say,
Speaker 2: well, hold on a second. If it's less
Speaker 1: serious, why would deaths go up? And
again, you could have something that's half
as serious but three times as contagious,
and you would still see deaths go
up 50 percent. I mean, it's very,
very crude math that doesn't exactly work
Speaker 2: that way, but that's basically the way
Speaker 1: that it is. In the meantime,
the UK is seeing absolutely record cases.
A number of different countries are seeing
really, really insane numbers. And the good
news, if there is any in
Speaker 2: the UK is that
Speaker 1: while the cases are going up
dramatically as Omicron takes over, deaths due to
Speaker 2: COVID are actually
Speaker 1: down over the last
two weeks. Now that may
Speaker 2: reverse what
what's the what's the possible
Speaker 1: counterpoint to?
It's very spreadable, but less
severe. The counterpoint would be
what if there is more of a delay before you
get really sick? In other words, we I think
Speaker 2: at one point the average
Speaker 1: interval between infection and death
was 17 days. At one point, it doesn't really
matter, but at one point it was roughly 17 days.
Is it possible that Omicron causes
mild disease for, I don't know,
five weeks. And then you get really
Speaker 2: sick and die?
Speaker 1: Doctors say it's possible, but
it's not very likely. So that's the good
news so far that. We can point to lastly, the
White House, there's been this question of would
the U.S. shut down again to the extent that the
U.S. ever did shut down? I think the answer is
Speaker 2: no for a couple of different
Speaker 1: reasons, unless there were to be a more
Speaker 2: severe variant, which we don't seem to
Speaker 1: have at this point in time. Number one,
at the state level, there are very few
states at this point that seem willing
to do anything even remotely approximating
a shutdown. That's number one. Number two,
Speaker 2: the White House is saying we are not
Speaker 1: going to do that. We are
Speaker 2: not going to have sweeping
Speaker 1: shutdowns, but we are seeing signs
that certainly raised questions as to what the
policy should be the hospitals becoming overrun.
Events being postponed. Some colleges and
universities already going back to remote. So
there are signs. But the White House
insists it's not going to happen
again if you get your third shot, and
that actually is 70 percent effective at
preventing symptomatic illness.
Speaker 2: And this is a more
spreadable, but less serious variant.
Speaker 1: If people do the right things,
you shouldn't have to shut down. If the shutdowns
become a real possibility, it would overwhelmingly
be because a lot of people aren't doing
the things that are available to us to do.
Let me know your thoughts. What do you think
will happen in the next one to two months?